BONGINO, LOU HOLTZ AND SEBASTIAN
GORKA.
WHETHER YOU LIKE THE PRESIDENT
OR NOT, WHAT SEPARATES HIM
FROMMER OTHER PRESIDENT IS THAT
HE'S NOT ONE TO HOLD HIS FINGERS
TO THE POLITICAL WIND BEFORE HE
MAKES A DECISION.
HE TRIES TO MAKE DECISIONS THAT
ARE RIGHT.
DECISIONS THAT ARE BEST FOR YOU
AND ME.
THEY ARE NOT ALWAYS POPULAR, AND
OF COURSE THE MOST OF DIFFICULT
ONES WILL ALWAYS BE QUESTIONED.
YESTERDAY'S DECISION WAS ONE OF
THEM.
THE DEAL WAS TO REOPEN THE
GOVERNMENT THROUGH FEBRUARY 15,
CREATING A BIPARTISAN, BY CAMERA
COMMITTEE WITH GORE YACHTING AN
AGREEMENT ON BORDER SECURITY.
THE PRESIDENT MADE IT CLEAR,
THOUGH, HE'S STICKING TO
BUILDING A BARRIER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: WE HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO BUILD A POWERFUL
WALL OR STEEL BARRIER.
IF WE DON'T GET A FAIR DEAL FROM
CONGRESS, THE GOVERNMENT WILL
EITHER SHUT DOWN ON FEBRUARY 15
AGAIN OR I WILL USE THE POWERS
AFFORDED TO ME UNDER THE LAWS
AND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES TO ADDRESS THIS
EMERGENCY.
JEAN REPORT ATTACKS WERE
IMMEDIATE, FULL BORE AND
RELENTLESS.
INSTEAD OF GIVING THE PRESIDENT
CREDIT FOR RECOGNIZING THE
DAMAGE TO THIS COUNTRY HE WAS
ATTACKED VIRTUALLY BY EVERYONE.
INSTEAD OF SAYING HE UNDERSTANDS
THE PURPOSE OF GOVERNMENT IS TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE.
HE SEES PEOPLE LIVING LIVING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
AIRPORTS CLOSED.
PREVENTING PEOPLE FROM BUSINESS
TRIPS, VISITING FAMILY MEMBERS
AS WELL AS THE ATTENDANT
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP.
UNLIKE THE OBSTRUCTIONISTS AND
THE TRUMP HATERS WHO DON'T GIVE
A DAMN ABOUT ORDINARY AMERICANS,
HE SIMPLY COULD NOT LET IT GO
ON.
HE DID NOT CAVE.
HE MADE A TACTICAL DECISION, A
STRATEGY DECISION TO PICK THE
GROUND TO FIGHT ON.
HE CHOSE TO STOP THE FIGHT TODAY
TO FIGHT ANOTHER DAY.
AND THAT DAY WILL BE FEBRUARY
15.
BUT OF COURSE CHUCK CORRODE.
>> HOPEFULLY NOW THE PRESIDENT
HAS LEARNED HIS LESSON.
NO ONE SHOULD EVER UNDERESTIMATE
THE SPEAKER AS DONALD TRUMP HAS
LEARNED.
JUDGE JEANINE: CHUCK, I HATE TO
BREAK IT TO YOU.
THIS ISN'T A GAME.
IT'S NOT ABOUT UNDERESTIMATING
PEOPLE.
IT'S ABOUT PEOPLE WITHOUT A
PAYCHECK.
SOMETHING YOU ARE NOT WILLING TO
GO WITHOUT.
AND NANCY GOT OFF HER BROOM LONG
ENOUGH TO SAY --
>> OUR UNITY IS OUR POWER.
THAT IS WHAT MAYBE THE PRESIDENT
UNDERESTIMATED.
JUDGE JEANINE: ANN COULTER
BLASTED TRUMP FOR NOT KEEPING
HIS PROMISE FOR THE BORDER WALL
SAYING HE LIED.
>> WE THOUGHT HE WOULDN'T CARE
WITH THE ELITES THOUGHT AND HE
WOULD KEEP HIS PROMISES ON THIS.
JUDGE JEANINE: HE STILL DOESN'T
CARE WHAT THE ELITES THOUGHT.
HE CAN'T TOLERATE AIRPORT
SHUTDOWNS AND YOU WANT TO
COMPARE HIM TO REAGAN WHEN
REAGAN FIRED THE STRIKING
AIRPORT CONTROLLERS.
OPM REGULATIONS, THE PRESIDENT
DOES NOT HAVE THE POWER TO FIRE
PEOPLE DURING A SHUTDOWN.
REAGAN FIRING THE AIR TRAFFIC
CONTROLLERS BECAUSE THEY WERE IN
VIOLATION OF THE LAW.
THAT SITUATION IS TOTALLY
DIFFERENT AND NOT ANALOGOUS.
PUBLIC SAFETY WORKERS HAVE NO
RIGHT TO STRIKE IT'S THE SAME
APPROACH CALVIN COOLIDGE TOOK
WHEN THE BOSTON POLICE WENT ON
STRIKE.
THESE PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY JUST WANT TO CRITICIZE HIM
LIKE THEY DID WITH OTHER
DECISIONS LIKE MEETING WITH KIM
JONG-UN.
WHO HASN'T LAUNCHED A WHAT WHRIS
PARTICULAR MEETING SINCE THE
MEETING.
LIKE THE TERRORISTS THAT WERE
UNPOPULAR BUT SEEM TO BE
WORKING.
THE WAR ISN'T OVER YET.
REMEMBER DONALD TRUMP IS A MAN
WILLING TO TAKE THE SHOT TO
CHANGE THE NORMS IN ORDER TO DO
WHAT HE THINKS IS BEST FOR THE
COUNTRY.
VERY OFTEN HE'S DEAD-ON.
CLOSING THE GOVERNMENT TORE AT
HIM.
OPENING IT WHETHER IT'S A POP
LASH MOVE IS IRRELEVANT IN HIS
MIND.
AND REMEMBER, THIS WAR IS NOT
OVER.
IT'S NOTHING BUT A HOLLOW
VICTORY FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
FEBRUARY 15 IF THE COMMITTEE
DOES NOT COME BACK WITH A
WORKABLE SOLUTION WHICH WOULD BE
A SHOCK TO ME BECAUSE CONGRESS
IS CERTAINLY NOT ABOUT GETTING
THE JOB DONE, THEY KICKED THE
CAN DOWN THE ROAD WITH THE
APPROVAL OF PRESIDENTS LIKE
OBAMA, CLINTON AND BUSH WITH NO
ONE LOOKING TO ACTUALLY GET
SOMETHING DONE.
THIS PRESIDENT COULD DO THE SAME
THING.
I BELIEVE HE'LL NOT.
BECAUSE ANOTHER CONTINUING
RESOLUTION IS NOT HIS STYLE.
I BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT WILL
CALL FOR EMERGENCY FUNDING FOR
THE WALL.
HE'S TRIED EVERYTHING ELSE.
THE ONLY THING I WOULD ASK IS
THAT HE MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T GET
TO THE 9th CIRCUIT, AKA THE
9th CIRCUIT.
THE IDEA OF CONGRESS GOING ON
YET ANOTHER VACATION THE DAY
AFTER FEBRUARY 15 WITH ALL OF
THIS UNSETTLED WITHOUT ANY KIND
OF RESOLUTION IS JUST ANOTHER
REMINDER TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
OF WHAT CONGRESS CARES ABOUT.
THEMSELVES, THEIR VACATIONS, AND
THE LOBBYISTS WHO FUND THOSE
VACATIONS.
I AM HERE TO TELL YOU, NEVER
UNDERESTIMATE THIS PRESIDENT.